Kate Middleton's fancy footwork goes
viral we're seeing The Duchess in a very
different light she is a very confident
poised self-assured woman the Princess
of Wales showed that confidence with her
Swift moves during her visit to
Copenhagen in February which is just
catching the internet's attention it all
happened as Kate posed for pictures with
Queen Margaret of Denmark and Crown
Princess Mary
at one point the queen motions for the
British royal to stand closer to her
Kate responds by discreetly scooting
closer via a heel toe slide
the move now being dubbed the princess
Shuffle I think there is a new
confidence about her I think that comes
with age
meanwhile Kate's preparing for another
big public event the coronation of her
father-in-law King Charles we are on the
eve of the most important and momentous
occasion in Charles's life the May 6
ceremony is not only a special moment
for Charles it's special for his
grandkids too including Prince William
and Kate's eldest son Prince George
don't forget this is all part of the
training for Prince George who will one
day be king Buckingham Palace says the
nine-year-old will serve as a page of
Honor a Kensington Palace spokesperson
tells E.T they're all very excited about
his role like Prince Charles when he was
that much younger just four watched his
mother crowned this will be Prince
George watching his grandfather crown
with his father looking onto knowing
that he will be next
George's siblings princess Charlotte and
Prince Louis will be a part of the
action too a royal Insider tells E.T
they will all have a high profile role
but as of now we'll only see George and
Charlotte inside of Westminster Abbey
for the coronation with William and Kate
in the same way that William always had
his wingman in Harry I think it's rather
wonderful that that is being echoed here
with George and Charlotte you know
you're going to see I think real
teamwork at place here as for
five-year-old Louis well that's still up
in the air and will be decided closer to
the date we can absolutely expect to see
Prince George and Princess Charlotte who
behaved so impeccably and on the day of
the Queen's funeral who've shown that
they are absolutely able to behave
according to a situation even one as
formal as this if Louis or any of the
kids end up getting out of hand no doubt
Kate will Shuffle into my mode like a
pro
[Music]
thank you